sébastien gendron vient de se lancer
dans un marathon
le français ancien ingénieur chez airbus
a quitté son pays en 2008 pour
travailler chez bombardier au québec
base est maintenant à toronto il veut
mettre en service le premier ipod look
de la planète
pour faire simple c'est un avion sans
ailes donc on est avec des capsules
quand la même forme qu un fuselage
d'avion avec une cabine pressurisée
comme ça des gens plus peuvent peuvent
respirer et ses capsules circulent dans
un tube en métal qui reliait avec des
pompes à vide
c'est un peu le même principe que le
courrier par pneumatiques mais beaucoup
plus rapide à une vitesse de plus de
1000 km à l'heure son projet il veut le
bâtir entre toronto et montréal insiste
annie pearl où va proposer aux usagers
la fréquence du métro avec la vitesse de
l'avion
la technologie n'est pas nouvelle et
surtout gendron n'est pas le seul dans
la course
l'idée lancée en 2013 par le
milliardaire de tesla elon musk a déjà
été reprise par un autre milliardaire
richard branson de la compagnie virgin
son high power l'open est déjà en test
dans le désert du nevada avec cette
courte piste d'essai est un peu partout
les projets similaires se multiplient
comme ici à toulouse où les premiers
morceaux de tuyaux pour eye pour look
ont fait leur apparition ce qu'on a vu
au nevada leçon sur 500 m à toulouse
c'est un kilomètre notre côté en est sur
3 km car devant la lenteur du projet
canadien le pdg de transport n'a pas mis
tous ses oeufs dans le même panier
à limoges à 3 heures au sud de paris il
est en train de finaliser sa ronde de
recherche d'investissements pour la
première pelletée terre l'automne
prochain et les premiers essais le
printemps suivant et le canada alors
pour l'instant québec et ottawa
regardent avec intérêt mais sans plus
pas d'argent sur la table
on reste circonspect devant l'attitude
prudente des gouvernements gendre ont
fait le tour du monde pour vanter son
projet et convaincre les investisseurs
on a clôturé une première levée de fonds
fin 2016 avec des investisseurs italiens
pour 20 millions de dollars canadiens
c'est un autre à notre niveau on imagine
par rapport aux milliardaires
c'est un autre niveau soit souvent je
prends la comparaison de david contre
goliath
après faut faire attention parce que
c'est david fiegen ou fait ce lien
montréal toronto convié coûterait-il
entre 15 et 20 milliards de dollars de
quoi faire frémir les gouvernements et
selon gendron les avantages sont
multiples guerres de productivité
empreinte environnementale moindre et
investissements durables avec un prix du
ticket entre 60 80 dollars on est sur
une rentabilité entre 30 et 40 ans mais
ce n'est pas pour tout de suite
2025 la certification du système par un
organisme comme transports canada et le
démarrage de la construction d'une
première ligne et idéalement au canada
bref cinq ans de plus pour le premier
passage et le premier billet vendu pour
2030 la légende en dire mais ça fait
encore douze ans attendre 12 ans voilà
douze ans donc vous n'avez pas fini
d'entendre parler du développement du
pearl ou en attendant la course folle au
premier arrêt au look se poursuit même
sans aucune garantie de succès ici
frédéric arnould radio-canada mourir
[Musique]
mais